[Applause]
[Music]
we had started this song
in la and i think we had you know the
verses
in the chorus and it needed something
you know we'd always sing it in
soundcheck and knew it was really cool
loved the melodies and uh loved the
message and uh
i went over to dan's house after being
quarantined for so long and
first of all it was amazing you know
getting to see him and be there in
person
dude you know this is like i missed you
because you know i see him
every day of my life and then you kind
of that's taken away from you
it's like you know your best friend is
just you know we felt like they are that
awesome the cute video of the kids
running and hugging on the sidewalk
that was kind of uh that was dana we
were so excited
[Music]
we've always been pretty diy with making
our records but you know in the past it
was always like if we needed to go
record an orchestra or if we needed to
record
a drummer like we've got the best
studios in the world here on music grow
so it's like boom you can jump in ocean
way
and get it done but right now you know i
think things are finally starting to
open back up which thank god i mean
we all need to get back in those studios
like those are essential for our
business but
when we made this record like those they
weren't open you know the musicians
weren't able to work unfortunately so it
was like
all right we got to just figure this out
on our own and i think sometimes
greatness can come with that you know
especially with
unlimited time access to time to just
figure it out
you know tinker and experiment until we
thought it was right there's nothing
like that connection
being in the room it's that's just like
it's electric being in the room with
your fans and feeling it from them
but i mean i think the responsible thing
to do right now is to just
step back and stay away from it as much
as we want to do it i mean
people are getting creative i think brad
paisley and some folks have had success
with the drive-in thing
and some people are doing live stream
concerts which is cool but now we're
just like
super zoned studio studio
bedroom mattress on the wall whatever
you call it
um we're in that space right now so
i don't know i'm sure i'll eat my words
whenever this song comes out and like
fans are saying hey can you we're gonna
be like okay yeah we'll come play an
acoustic show in your front yard or
something so
yeah i don't know we're gonna try to get
creative with it but you know we're
missing the road more than anything
[Music]
you